hey guys it's Justine and today we are
gonna be talking about this this is the
new ish Polaroid camera this is the one
step plus they have two different
versions that came out with this one has
bluetooth and it also has a couple other
features but it still is like those
vintage Polaroid cameras that you guys
have seen in the past like this develops
film like on the back here it says that
it will develop within ten to fifteen
minutes that's a lot of minutes but I'm
excited to try this out but here's the
thing Facebook and Instagram have been
targeting me and they've been targeting
me hardcore because every time I see a
freaking ad pop up it is something that
I've either talked about or I've wanted
or have thought in my mind long story
short this was an ad and here it is
we're gonna unbox this and then we're
gonna take it out I also have some foam
here that I got I probably should have
got a little bit more because this won't
take 8 photos 8 so now with this guy
this will also connect to bluetooth like
I said Joe what's cool about it is you
can do different things when you connect
it to Bluetooth so you can control the
camera you can do remote man you load
some timer double exposure like painting
noise trigger I'm not sure what that is
but we will find out so let's open it up
shake it like pull the rope it you've
got directions
okay okay
oh geez you can't be doing things like
that I think it's ready to go I'm gonna
do a portrait neutral a lighter image or
darker image so you can adjust exposure
here we've got your focus here got your
on and off here and this is I guess for
a flash that's gonna be my best work
that's a complete accident okay I wanna
try to take a selfie well if I don't
want the flash on blinking blue camera
is in pairing mode oh it's ready to
connect to bluetooth we're not ready for
that yet or are we oh it's already
somebody here that's my camera double
exposure this is something that I'm
excited about light painting so I'm
gonna take a picture
Oh myself it's gonna be off okay all
right well I guess I'll let those
develop I'm gonna charge this up and
then we're gonna take it outside and
take some photos see we can capture
[Music]
we're down here in Santa Monica now and
I've got the camera and it should be
charged up I charged it for quite a
while and we're gonna take some pictures
I'm gonna also pair it to the app so
that I can do some cool things so I want
to take a double exposure so I'm gonna
take a picture of myself first okay am I
ready
I don't know now a little tip that we
found out is there's a button back here
this will force the flash to not entire
so we will take up a server here I'm
gonna look through here there's my coat
oh there's Jenna a while Jenna
show me your shirt show me that shirt
yeah you look good I could really take
four more pictures ready I feel like I'm
from 1984 I do want to do a test of kind
of showing which each one of these
exposures kind of would look like okay
this is Tyler Tyler whoa so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do the low
exposure the middle one and then the
high yes and see what the difference is
yes okay here you go
okay so right now we're on the darker
mode here we go
Wow that's satisfying that's very
satisfying okay so now let's just the
neutral exposure setting
fun and now we're doing the bright
setting bright and shining like my super
shiny
you look so good oh did I go oh I think
you need to put more film in there
oh my god oh my gosh should I put the
rose gold film in we're gonna try the
landscape setting so we're gonna be a
little further away from our subject so
we're going to lose
that's gonna be cool I blink I was
kidding I don't know if it it okay look
at this rose gold frame though Oh shake
it shake don't shake it
see sometimes we have to do double
exposure so you
put the camera where you want it how do
you do it just push the button can I do
it yeah you can okay cool okay so we're
gonna do a portrait we're back on the
portrait setting here as the first photo
oh god okay we can do this
cool and then the second photo I'm just
going to shoot straight up at this tree
for like a weird texture we should try
this
the noise trigger oh yeah okay so once
it's turned on the noise trigger will
automatically take a picture when the
volume is high enough I'm gonna click
okay
yeah yeah
turpentine so you can set the noise
triggers if you wanted to be super loud
okay so I'm gonna try to do a jump but
I'm gonna try to have it capture my junk
I think it works
he should okay we've got some black and
white we're gonna try now so the first
thing I'm gonna try the black and white
is do a double exposure I think the
double exposure is probably one of my
favorite features of this thing it's so
easy to do let's do it
okay there's my first picture now I'm
gonna get
super close-up yeah that's my new
profile pic Jenna come here can I want
to take a picture of you there's no time
for that
I'm sure it'll be just fine now I'll
just take a picture of I don't know I'll
just take some pictures these are gonna
be going in the museum let me get a
picture of all of our feet let's all get
our feets in here okay okay this is cool
this is gonna be the museum I'm gonna
get a selfie
[Music]
two pictures left okay Tyler look super
cool that's nice it's very nice how
about I'll just take another one of
these that's nice
these seem to start developing faster
than the color
okay I'll add these to collection we're
back from our adventure time to see what
these rose gold frames are really really
pretty
so the focal length of the selfie is
actually really good
this one looks so cool it's like a
vintage grilled cheese this was the one
where I was using the sound activated
it's not my best face but Tyler look
that look you this is so great the
double exposure is it's so awesome I
also have oh my gosh this was the noise
activated one where I jumped up in the
air and said the v-league if you're
trying to decide between which one to
get I would kind of recommend this one
because this will allow you to connect
to the app and you can do all kinds of
things like the double exposure and you
can use your phone to control it it also
has this thing that I saw while we're
driving in the car on our way to shoot
it has this little setting where you can
actually scan the photos so you can
archive them into your phone which is
basically you're just taking a picture
of a Polaroid so I don't know if it
doesn't make special let's try it out oh
it just took the picture by itself whoa
okay I wasn't even like I didn't even do
anything it just did it by itself this
is a really cool idea so it does allow
you to sort of save your pictures into
the camera roll
like you guys so much for watching this
was really fun let me know if there's
anything else you guys would like me to
check out also let me know if there's
any Instagram ads take screenshots of
them and send them to me cuz I would
love to see what you guys are getting
served and if it's something cool maybe
I'll buy it check it out I'll give you
guys credit for setting me in that image
anyway that's it these are my photos I'm
excited to play with this a little bit
more also go check out Tyler's Instagram
he's the one helping me film this video
and he took some of these photos and his
photos are so good and look he's got a
smile on his face
they're really cool so go check it out
and I will see you guys in my next video
peace
[Music]